tonight is very exciting because we're
going to introduce a new service
provided exclusively at comic-con for
expectant mothers isn't that nice yeah a
lot of that's enough a lot of a lot of
pregnant women have these really fun
gender-reveal parties where they'll cut
into a cake or pop a balloon it will
reveal pink or blue indicating the
gender of their child it's a big thing
these days well we have a new gender
reveal service just for comic-con fans
I'm just curious do we have any pregnant
women in the audience any pregnant she's
praying with do you mind coming up on
stage is that Alright hey sure okay come
on let's give her a hand everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for being here what's
your name
Tesla Tesla okay Tesla how many months
along are you seven Wow okay getting
close do you know the gender of your
baby no my husband doesn't want to know
but I'm actually kind of curious okay
all right
this is cool we have a doctor here we've
arranged have a doctor here who's going
to help you find out the gender of your
baby please welcome our friend dr. Bruce
Banner let's get him out here
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Ashley how are you
right I'm great I'm a big fan dr. banner
oh thanks okay now dr. banner how are
you able to tell the gender of her baby
well not many people know this Conan but
one of the side effects of gamma
radiation is the ability to predict
gender Esley are you excited to find out
yes okay all I need from you is to kick
me in the genitals sure again oh one
more time oh I'm just not quite angry
enough okay well how about this
I think the Angley hope is the best hope
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is incredible
The Hulk is blue you're having a boy
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah thanks a lot huh oh don't touch ho
oh all right well anyway congratulations
Tesla this is fantastic news and you are
gonna have a boy we're all excited
please accept this baby shower gift I'm
really happy for you to have cool stuff
in there there's ready there there's
some diapers yeah and there's a little
bit of like rubber ducky because you're
[Applause]
something for the baby and a hug for you
you know some green stuff like that well
anyway thank you very much everybody
[Applause]
you
[Applause]